I'd like to introduce you to my friend
Benjamin and his friend Benjamin and his
friend Benjamin and Benjamin and
Benjamin and Benjamin and Benjamin this
is what's called ten racks as they say
in the hood okay I don't even know how
to start this welcome to fake guru
number nine today we're talking about as
they say in the hood
the cringy I cringe iasts fake guru that
we've seen so far
John crostini as they say in the hood if
you haven't seen his ads okay they're
pretty pretty crazy they're pretty they
promise a lot okay he's all about the
Benjamins and I'm gonna show you how to
make the Benjamin's how to make friends
with some of these guys make time for
money okay stop it
first I don't mean to nitpick here do
you trust anybody with this haircut do
you do you really do you trust your
money with a haircut like the ball cut
thing anyone can become a fake guru
these day this guy's living proof than
anybody you got a hipster beard you got
a terrible haircut YouTube can you could
promise money you get you just need a
rack as they say in the hood I'm gonna
show you the way and it's really
exciting on the other side so let's get
let's get it let's get let's get it look
let's let's get it let's let's get it on
the other side of the paywall
let's get it I'll see you on the
training and I'm gonna hurry up and sign
up for his exclusive live webinar which
he just invited me to I'm super excited
and he's gonna show me how to make tons
of money okay let's let's sign up for
this real quick all right we're in boys
let's let's go to the live character by
the way I do 400 people in here how is
this in the camera yes John we could see
it
of course you're holding it right up to
the camera of course we could see it
dude he takes he gets you to sign up to
a webinar by showing you a rack as they
say in the hood and then goes in his
firt and his webinar the first thing he
does is show you another rack this guy's
so cringe hundred dollar bills this is
this is called a rack
okay this is a rack as they say in the
hood 100 hundred dollar bills and you
can see it and I'm actually oh this is
not affiliate marketing but okay that's
not that's drug money dude don't do it
trust this guy immediately he's like
Walter White this guy is sketch from the
beginning Blaine to you why I have all
this money here in a second but if you
look it's not just to make you guys want
to be like me that is all real money so
yeah and I'll explain this significant I
actually even have a private security
guard here is this all real money yeah
yeah I did just pay this guy to be here
he's real he's real I stood here dude
so is this webinar worth your time um if
you're wondering if you did not already
see that the piles of money that are are
available by dude did you see the piles
of money like how many more piles of
money do I need to show you to get you
interested I'll go to the bank and get a
loan i watch my webinar so is this
webinar worth your time let me just skip
this it's like this super long webinar
basically it's all used to just upsell
you on what is called the internet jet
set which is John crostinis exclusive
product it's 997 it's a it's a grand
it's a grand for a six week course which
is just teaching affiliate marketing
guys it's just teaching affiliate
marketing but here's the thing affiliate
marketing is already taught on YouTube
for free you don't have to spend a
thousand dollars I mean look at this
affiliate marketing for beginners this
free stuff free stuff most of it as it
should be this stuff is not hard you
should not be paying some you don't need
a guru
teach you basic affiliate marketing like
there's endless resources so what is it
that's that is making people buy this
thing because recently John Kriss Donnie
said that he made some somewhere in the
range of three hundred thousand dollars
in a month from this program meaning
three hundred suckers went and bought
his product but why did they buy his
product over any other because everyone
who's taken it usually says oh it's just
a course for beginners why are people
why are people making paying him a
thousand dollars for his program and
that's sort of where the fake guru side
of this comes in because this is where
the marketing comes in this is where the
cash the cats guys comes in this video
is about how to make money online and
what really gets me about this no money
free money easy money fast money I'm
gonna show you how to make money online
without dealing with any scams fast easy
and free and I'm gonna be showing you on
my little laptop right here it's a big
laptop big whopper talk about how you
can make money doing this with Amazon
and eBay I'm sure you guys tired of
furious there's no such thing over and
over this video I'm gonna show you how
to make quick money in one day online
and by quick money it's gonna be big
money I'm not going to show you some way
to make five or ten or twenty dollars in
a day online I'm gonna show you how to
make big money and I'm gonna walk you
through step by step right here on my
Gregoire home exactly what you need to
do
cuz I have money too how about we try
this how about you don't how about how
much you just don't listen to that
how about ya assume that to make money
you probably need some skills you
probably need not only technical skills
you need to work really hard become slow
or you could get jump honestly I don't
know why these fake gurus not having a
regular job so hard I really don't
understand it and often times you can
make more money just working in
McDonough's job start with job
then you'll ever make for these people
and you're not going to spend a penny
getting the job and you're gonna make
you're definitely making money with
these people you spend a ton of money
there's no guarantees if you make
anything and most the time you don't
make anything because the person's real
experience is just taking people like
you or your money I don't know you can
choose the businessman boy or you can
choose his power his buddy the
Washington man the Washington look I've
got look at Washington's friends look at
this I got another Washington for a
while this is what they call them the
hood being broke that's it for fake
gurus today okay and as always let's get
let's get it
[Music]
Sakura